[Music]
my name is Navid Ahmad I am a senior
director for data engineering and
machine learning at Hearst Newspapers my
responsibilities are to build the data
pipeline data warehousing and using that
data to build data products and
predictive data science you might not
have heard about Hearst but you might
have heard of names like San Francisco
Chronicle or SF Gate or Houston
Chronicle or magazine names like Esquire
or cosmopolitan or men's health so the
company behind this is a Hearst it's one
of the biggest media companies in USA
I'm here to talk about the work we've
done with Hearst Newspapers Hearst
newspaper employs about 4,000 people
across the country it focuses on local
news and it has about 40 websites and
in+ websites and it's continuously
growing and you can find more
information about Hearst at this link
and these are some of the name brands
that I just talked about you might be
more familiar with San Francisco
Chronicle newspaper in this California
area so this is sort of like our data
strategy at Hearst newspaper it might
vaguely look like the mass love
hierarchy of needs
if so data is the essential thing
without data you can do data science or
business intelligence so our strategy
was to first build a data warehouse and
I'll take some minutes to talk about our
what we did with bigquery and and top of
it as its business intelligence which
helps inform people in marketing
editorial and product to make decisions
on historical data and then using the
same data that you can use for his to
look at historical data you can
predictive analysis and then also build
products using that data talk a little
about a big query so why centralized
data is if you have all the data in one
place you can connect the dots so if you
have data sets of newsletters and Google
Analytics and your content database you
can make easily make connections versus
if they were sitting in different
database you'll have to you know it
becomes difficult and it's efficient for
users to go into one place to get that
data there's no duplication you're not
getting reports from one place and then
to different places and those numbers
don't match up and it's efficient and
data warehousing use the same project
management product engineering and QA
and consolidate your efforts and most
importantly relevant to this talk is
it's the foundation for ml and why did
we use bigquery before this we people
used to either pull reports from
different systems email them out there
were different data bases different data
warehouses so a couple of years ago we
thought that we need to consolidate
everything into one database and we
chose bigquery and these are some of the
reasons why bigquery was choice it's
based on dream old technology and this
stuff is on on their website terabytes
and seconds and petabytes and minutes to
be able to query that data it's fully
managed sequel every lots of people know
sequel so easy to get people onto
bigquery and now with yesterday's
release of bigquery ml you can even do
machine learning on top of bigquery so
this is the technology stack for our BI
platform we're using ETL using air flow
bigquery as a Darrow warehouse and
looker and I think there's been other
talks talking about how people have used
looker with bigquery to build
user journeys and stuff so we're also
doing it that could be a separate dog
but I'm just mentioning that we we are
also doing this and these are some of
the data sources we have in bigquery
Google Analytics double-click
subscriptions newsletters and this is
continuously growing the the number of
datasets in our data warehouse so
getting to machine learning so I see
machine learning and two big buckets one
machine learning that's prepackaged that
Google has done your data science work
for you and they've exposed api's to be
able to do and these are natural
language processing auto ml which was
also released in this conference speech
video intelligence and vision and the
other half is where your data science
and your doing machine learning in-house
using tensor flow / cloud ml bigquery ml
and using data proc and spark so there
was a case study published back in
November of how Hearst Newspapers using
natural language processing and the
different use cases so the the two
pieces that we've used from natural
language processing is to be able to
extract entities and categories from our
text there's a part of speech API that
we haven't used but this this alone we
have about six use cases using these
features so I took an article from San
Francisco Chronicle this is about the
this movie black panther and ran it
through the web interface from Google
and you can see that it has correctly
detected Black Panther as a work of art
it has a Wikipedia link it also has
knowledge ID and also the saliency score
and naturally the entities are broken
down into different categories there is
work of art places organization
locations and then that is further
broken down into proper and improper
nouns and then it also correctly
detected the right category for it
and also given the confidence score so
these are so using justice this is all
good but how do we use this thing that
you looks very simple
so the I'm gonna go through some of
these use cases across is how to use
Google NLP you can from a simple use
case of displaying these tags on our CMS
system to building a recommendation
system and also matching ads to the
right content so I'll go one at a time
on and this is sort of like the high
level architecture of how everything
connects so when context is ingested
into our CMS system we make these NLP
calls get the meta data back and store
it into our database and then when the
article is rendered these tags are part
of the meta tag of the HTML and from
that we have a third-party customer data
platform which is extracting these NLP
tags and into its system and at the same
time there's a JavaScript call that for
to double-click for publishers to be
able to render ads and also this data is
pushed into bigquery our CMS content
along with the NLP tags are also pushed
into bigquery upon which we can do bi
reporting and then also build a
recommendation system on it
so first use case segmentation
segmentation is that be able to identify
a group of users say which group of
users are sports readers versus like
food and wine readers so you that our
CDP platform has a built in mechanism to
be able to use these tags to create
segments and what how these segments are
users that you can push marketing
messaging like let's say if you if you
know there's a segment above you know
people who like to read tennis news you
can push a newsletter using this tool
the other use cases DFP ad targeting so
I had mentioned that we are making in
our key value pairs we can pass in a key
of the NLP category and the actual
category that was for that page so what
this does is DFP over a month it can
collect all this data and then one can
run reporting on it telling how users
and how ads were displayed across our
content and then if another customer
says hey I want to have a campaign to
target Olympics web pages put my ad on
Olympic web pages they can create a
campaign with a certain criteria and now
this vendors ads or because the partners
ads can just be displayed on Olympics
content so this is just a screenshot of
how like the rules are set and DFP since
this is a bi report it uses Google
Analytics wcm content and the NLP data
to come up with some useful numbers
within this report it's showing for this
category these are the number of users
who visited and these are the number of
articles in that category and a simple
ratio could show that a higher ratio
would mean that this is something
editorial should focus on this category
write more content about it
and there's numerous different things
you can do if you have google analytics
NLP and content database for example you
can create trend graphs about a certain
topic or a certain personality how their
their fame are they getting more famous
or less famous over the years like
content wise and this is another
analysis of so we get content from third
parties how which third parties give
what type of content like does this
source give us more sports content
versus the other one and again you can
build different kind of reports using
this so I'll get into recommendation
systems
so why recommendation system important
so next if you might have read Netflix
values there is their recommendation
that one billion dollars so in our
context if we could reuse older content
which is just sitting still and nobody
is using it or looking at it that this
could increase engagement people would
stay on the website longer which means
more ad revenue and eventually people
might even subscribe right now people
tend to go to the home page and whatever
links over there are that's the content
they can see but if we can use our
recommendation system to explores older
content that would be very useful so
these are three different types of
recommendation system that are supported
by the google cloud so we did a content
to content recommendation system
personalized recommendation system and a
video to content recommendation system
so since we had the NLP data with the
content data sitting and bigquery it was
a very low
food to build a recommendation system
and the core concept of this as any two
articles which have high overlapping NLP
entities are related to each other and
the this this is essentially a big SQL
with certain rules and you know
conditions that we created and runs on a
periodic basis like every twenty minutes
as new content comes in ran the sequel
so let me show the diagram for this we
run that sequel and bigquery store that
and cloud SQL and it's fronted by a
kubernetes web service layer to serve
these recommendations and on from the
front-end like there's a Java Script
call to render these recommendations so
and that API called you just they pass
in the Content ID we find all the
related content that's already pre
computed in cloud SQL a Postgres
database and render down so continuing
on this concept so this was actually a
hack day idea we had a hack day and I
did this prototype to see we could
extract anything useful from video so we
took our videos convert extract the
sound using a ffmpeg tool as open source
and use that sound to make a call to the
speech API which gives you back the text
for that video and then you again you
can run NLP on that text as well as
combine it with the metadata for the
video and you'll get NLP tags back
so right now our again just like our
text contest is just when we ingest the
video content we're storing the metadata
the transcript as well as the metadata
tags along with it let me back though
and what we did was that since we have
these NLP tags this power is another
recommendation system to
recommend videos to text since our text
already has NLP ties and our we've
extracted these NLP tags from video now
we can build an in-house recommendation
system so this saved our company some
money instead of buying like a video to
text recommender we just build using NLP
and search technology to build our own
recommendation system so this project we
worked in collaboration with our TV
Department
this is using tensorflow talk a little
bit about what tensorflow is you might
have already heard in neural networks
are back and the current deep learning
revolution is because of deep neural
networks they're bigger and hierarchical
and many of the Google products
especially in the AI are based on tensor
flow and cloud ml is a managed version
of tensor flow so we build an in-house
personalized recommendation system that
could be like one whole talk talking
about how the algorithm and how it works
and the full architecture of it but it
essentially in summary it's using scalar
vector decomposition and basically a
collaborative filtering algorithm and
that algorithm is something that you can
fit into tensor flow because you can
solve it through great great using
gradient descent and tensor flow library
helps you solve algorithms that can be
put into a gradient descent problem and
it's basically looking at the user's
history and also the history of people
who are who have similar taste to it and
there's a open source implementation
Google released using Google Analytics
CMS content and to build the
recommendations and I'll encourage you
to take a look at a bit similar to what
we did
and the high-level architecture is we're
reading our content from content and
Google Analytics data from bigquery and
you see there's another advantage that
all the data is sitting in bigquery do
some pre-processing and then run this
tensor flow model and then this tensor
flow model gets stored that's the output
of the tensor flow and it's fronted by
tensor flow serving tensor flow serving
is RPC layer that helps you deliver the
recommendations on this model and then
it's fronted by a restful web service
layer some of the other use case for a
tensor flow is to do propensity modeling
forecasting content virality prediction
build customer content class version of
content so I actually also had churn
modeling and that's a use case that I
built in bigquery ml and I'll be talking
about it so some of the now Google
offers you a variety of ways of doing
machine learning so it's a question of
what's the most what makes sense is you
have to figure out what makes sense to
use tensor flow versus Bikram ml versus
auto ml and all these other API so I
gave a talk about Vickrey ml yesterday
so why bigquery ml for Hearst Newspapers
as I already told you that all our data
is already sitting in bigquery so this
was made a lot of sense to just do this
using BQ ml I enabled anyone with
familiar with SQL to get on board and
start doing machine learning and the
alternate would be to first learn R or
Python learns a framework like
scikit-learn or
sir Flo but over here using bqm oh you
don't need to learn any of those you
don't need to ETL data out do a machine
learning outside and then ETL stuff back
in everything gets done in place and
goodies like a normalization and one hot
encoding it it it just does it for you
and then you have other sequel syntax to
get evaluation of your machine learning
model right in bigquery so it's a
relevant churn prediction it's a
relevant use case for medium because you
might have heard people have choices and
it's hard to keep them keep the
subscribers so if we could figure out a
way or have some insight into the future
of which subscribers are going to cancel
we could say so I put up reverb money
saved as money made or subscribers it is
money made and I thought of two more
yesterday I saw that I'll tell you
another one so prevention is better than
cure
and one in hand is better than two in
the bush so this just proves that I
passed my English test this gives you
insights into the future of cancellation
of subscribers it's to class so it's a
binary logistic regression people who
cancel and who didn't and we're using we
took one year of data of our
subscription newsletter demographic web
browsing all of that data again is
sitting in bigquery so the architecture
is really simple it's a really two nodes
bigquery and looker but I put in a few
steps of what happens so we're each
yelling in all our data sets using air
flow doing a little bit of
pre-processing of our Google Analytics
data like making some summary tables
especially of how subscribers and a
browsing set and then third step is the
real machine learning step you just do
create model the model name and then you
give it a table with all of the columns
with the features and one column is the
label column and the label in our case
is did this person cancel or not and
then when you run this query it takes
about four or five minutes you go and
grab a cup of tea or coffee and when
you're back the query number four is you
run select star from predict on a table
which has existing subscribers existing
current subscribers and for those
subscribers it'll give you a score of
the probability score of how likely they
were to cancel and then we built a bunch
a dashboard and a bunch of looks in it
which show the output of the result and
also the output of our machine learning
matrix such as ROC or precision and
recall so this is a snapshot of a
dashboard so the first look is basically
showing all the subscribers sorted by
how likely they are to cancel their
subscription and somebody in the
subscription retention team or can take
a look at it and at least have an idea
of what this is predicting how like do
some forecasting this number on the
right side is the AUC curve is called
area under the curve score it's
essentially the area under this other
graph and it's a data science ething but
what it means is that if this AUC score
was 50% then our machine learning model
hadn't learned anything meaning that
this line over here for that's a plot of
false positive versus too positive would
just be a horizontal line but this shows
a that our data has predictive power and
to that be qml does the
is learning something and on the right
we're applauding the same graph which is
the true positive rate and the false
positive rate so another problem you
have to figure out is what probability
the probability threshold above which
you say that this person is a gern or
not do you say like 50% above or 30% and
above so this graph over here on the
bottom on the right side shows a plot of
true positive and the false positive
rate and we want to have a threshold
which gives us a decent to positive and
also a low false positive rate so we
chose some about 0.3 which gives us
about 18% false positive and 80% true
positive rate which I feel is fine
because even if you send out you know
emails to the people you who you think
are going to churn and if they don't end
up churning it doesn't hurt you just
send out extra emails and this is a plot
of so you can also get the weights of
your learned model to get an idea what
it's learning so this is a plot of the
weights these thing so features that are
on the left are positively correlated to
churn while the features on the right
are negatively correlated returned and
it gives us a sense that let's look at
this feature there might be some clue in
our historical data that we might be
able to take some business decisions or
change the way how we're doing business
and and reduce our churn and it has two
types of features one is just numerical
features on one and are the others are
categorical features so you have to do
unnecessary qual to be able to get those
other features and you can look up at
the B qml tutorials with examples of
other use cases to do predictive
modeling
so you auto ml for text was released in
this conference so while this was an
alpha being working with the product
manager and built a model for ourselves
so we have two main use cases that are
the discussion about DFP being able to
match ads we also want to enhance some
of our categories for example take the
sensitive subject category and break it
down into more granular ones or like if
there's a new sports that's not covered
by the default categories we want to
train our own so that's one use case the
other use cases that I worked over here
is to be able to detect evergreen
content to be an evergreen content is
content that has a longer lifespan for
example a review of a restaurant or a
museum will call it evergreen content
but a story about some accident that
happened in a mall it only has a few
days or a few weeks life so you want to
be able to differentiate content that's
evergreen or not so initially I tried
this open source data set from stumble
upon from Kaggle very initially I try to
write my own tensorflow code using LS TM
I just quickly prototyped and felt that
it it the data had predictive power but
I knew that Google I had some hunch that
Google was working on something like
this so so so then we created a data set
of our own data set to label evergreen
content so it was sort of like
internally crowd sourced through to our
CMS a word editor is basically tagged
some of this content as evergreen and to
use auto ml is really easy you take a
create a CSV file give it the first
column as the content and the second
column as the label everyone or not
evergreen and then upload
- Auto ml and have it run learned from
this data so you see this we had about
3,000 articles for every being and
another 3,000 for non evergreen and you
see it has done a pretty good job and
learning this thing I was surprised that
it couldn't do so well and you see the
precision recall score and this is the
it also shows the confusion matrix of
what it predicted it 91% of the time non
evergreen content it predicted as no one
ever green and only 9% of time it made a
mistake for non evergreen content and
for every being and did a perfect job
and this is only on the test database so
I took this and say I played around and
tried in the auto ml console you can put
in any random text and see how your
prediction model does so I try to run
our Hearst articles I tried on CNN
articles and it seemed to work very well
and then I even went to Wikipedia so I
picked up an article about New York so
that you think is evergreen and it
corrected the 70% it predicted that is
this is evergreen and then from again
from Wikipedia I picked an article about
Mexico elections and it predicted is non
evergreen so it's basically the the
combined knowledge of editorials of what
they think is evergreen and non
everybody in this auto ml has learned
and is able to apply on text that it
hasn't seen before
so ideally we want to use bigquery for
most of our analytic process anything
that can be formulated as SQL I tend to
want to use bigquery because it's
distributed and it's more cost effective
to do things in bigquery
but there are some use cases that it's
it like very few use cases that you have
to do these things outside of bigquery
so one of the use cases that we have
duplicate content content which either
their body looks very similar or the
headline is tweaked and essentially it's
the same article and we don't want to
recommend articles that are similar to
each other in a list of recommendations
so and what we wanted to do initially
was and bigquery like creative were to
work of each article and then then do a
across join with itself and create
figure out the distance between those
articles and doing this and BIC raid was
not possible because it wouldn't that
query wouldn't return so what we did is
in this use case we used spark basically
spawned up a cluster of 10 machines for
a couple of hours and we wrote a PI
spark job to compute these vectors and
basically compute the cosine distance
between articles and articles that had
were very close to each other we
eliminated them as duplicates this helps
our recommendation system to remove any
duplicate content and a use case of
spark and data proc in our data so I'm
getting close at this is actually my
last slide so what's the future of
Hearst Newspapers so we want to build
more predictive models using bigquery
and ml because it makes a lot of sense
to since we all have all the day
it's very easy to use bicker EML things
like propensity modeling like the
reverse of churn modeling is to figure
out who are the subscribers that are
likely to subscribe or who are the
visitors on our webpages were likely to
subscribe and this could help our
marketing systems like focus on those
and actually and yesterday's be QML demo
the demo was about figuring out those
people that are likely because future
customers we want to production lies the
the taxonomy I was talking about we
already have requirements to an auto ml
want to create our own data sets and
train it to enhance our the NLP taxonomy
there's been lots of research using deep
neural networks for recommendation
systems there's actually one article
which lists all the different research
papers using deep neural networks for
recommendation system and we've been
prototyping a few different approaches
like these hybrid approaches there's all
sorts of different flavors of doing
recommendations systems using deep
learning so that research is continuing
and hopefully we could our version two
will be a more even more advanced
recommendation system there's still more
juice to be taken out from Google NLP
that we haven't fully utilized the NLP
especially some of the use cases are
being able to build personalized
newsletters or topic pages using Google
NLP so we are like thinking on these
other use cases and how to production
Eliza's and also we have a large corpus
of images haven't yet reached that point
to build a product around it so that's
one of the things that I have for the
future
[Music]